- It is a kid's show, right?
- Well...
- We're going to be watching
The Chilling Adventures of Sabrina.
Sabrina is a half-human, half-witch.
You know, we used to burn witches.
- Yeah, we did.
- I'm like, what's this about?
- I read about her in the comics.
- When were they out?
- The Dark ages.
- Excuse me.
- Ambrose!
Can anyone explain why it looks like
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
has been nailed to our door?
- It means our family's
been selected to participate
in this year's Feast of Feasts.
- So, the celebration of the Feast
is a celebration of cannibalism.
- If you change a few of the words,
it almost sounds like church last night.
- Tonight we celebrate a
time-honored tradition,
the Feast of Feasts.
- No, I think they're
actually gonna have a lottery
and whoever wins it is
the person who dies.
- And then they eat that person.
- The Lord's Supper is sort
of cannibalistic, isn't it?
Like, we eat the body of
Jesus Christ, interesting.
- Drink his blood.
- Yeah.
- Prudence is queen.
- And they think this is a great honor.
- It's religious diversity.
- Darling, can I have a warm
buttermilk bath tonight, please?
- I can't think of anything
worse than a buttermilk bath.
- Uh, I--
- You're killing the mood, Shepard.
- You're killing the mood.
- Great.
- Either get in or get out.
- Awkward.
- If you're a witch it's all--
- Sure.
- Very holy.
- It's a bit dark there.
- Yeah, that's right, we can't really see.
- It's like the exact
negative, reverse, opposite
of all of traditional Christian values.
- So, they just inverted it all, right.
What is that?
- Form a pentagram around the creature.
- Wait, Ms. Wardwell, what are we doing?
- Pulling the wool over their eyes.
- That's pretty cool.
The Dark Lord shall behold
- Praise Satan!
- I'm not a fan of this.
- Isn't your church like this?
Although, I'm getting some ideas.
- What?
- Uggggh.
- Do they have to give
her some sort of spices
or anything like that to
make her a bit more tasty?
- Ugh.
- I shouldn't laugh at that.
- Let sticks and stones break
the witch hunter's bones.
- I won't be watching Sabrina again.
- I really enjoy Sabrina.
- I thought Sabrina was
really well produced
and I thought it asks
some profound questions
about what it is to believe.
- I would highly recommend it.
I think sometimes it's important
to go outside of your
faith to actually really
understand what it is you believe.
- I think in some ways it is a parody
of traditional Christianity,
so I can appreciate some of the points
it was trying to make.
I would have preferred a
little bit less cannibalism.
I gotta go home and try one
of those buttermilk baths.
- Seriously?
- No.